Rachel, Hello Louis,
look at you
As to finding bodies it's chaos out there
This house is being requisitioned by the British government.
Hey Luis. Hello Morgan. Please come inside; this is my wife
My daughter and I will stay out of your way until we move to the camp
What if we let them stay warm? You mean, live with him?
There may not be an outward show of hatred but it is there below the surface
During the war did you ever hope for a German victory?
Did the bombing affect the health of you and your family? It affected the health of my wife.
She died in the firestorm
I'm so sorry
You didn't tell me what I was walking into
This isn't how it was supposed to be. None of this is how it is supposed to be
Please don't go. I have a job to do
You're going to spy on a girl the least you could do is pay her a compliment. Yes, of course
Something's changed, be careful. That's all. They aren't like us
I never thought that I could be happy like this.
come with me, this is what you wanted
To new beginnings